the next recipient of the Annie Taylor
award personifies courage and being on
edge of the defense against the spread
of elements of Islamic law in the United
States and for her efforts in defense of
human rights in defense of America
defense of Israel defense of
judeo-christian civilization
she has been demonized ridiculed mocked
and of course threatened with death and
yet she's never given up and never will
give up even Annie Taylor said nobody
should ever do that again but the next
winner of this award keeps on doing it
she has taken the battle to the Islamic
supremacists in the United States and
put them on the defensive like nobody
ever has before calling attention to the
human rights abuses that are inherent in
Islamic law in unprecedented and
imaginative ways that have put and
brought national attention that has
never before been directed to subjects
like honor killing the death penalty for
apostasy and of course the sinister
intent behind the Ground Zero mosque she
created and placed all over the country
bus ads that offered help to people who
were leaving Islam they were as the
media always does distort the truth
they were mischaracterized as asking
people to leave Islam or inviting them
to do so actually this was a real offer
for help for people that the whole world
has ignored his law mandates a death
penalty for apostasy Mohammad said if
anybody changes his religion kill him
but nobody ever cares for those people
have you ever heard Amnesty
International or Human Rights Watch say
a word about apostates from Islam who
are under the threat of death every day
of their lives
she brought national attention to this
issue and never before had the Islamic
supremacists grouped like the Council on
american-islamic relations never before
had they experienced this kind of
pushback never before had they been put
on the defensive and the campaign was
brilliantly
sieved because if you think about it
what could Kerr say well actually yes we
do think the apostates should be killed
we don't think that people who are
threatened ought to be offered help
never before had their agenda and their
pseudo moderation been so thoroughly and
completely exposed
she put ads on taxi tops with pictures
of beautiful young girls who had been
murdered murdered by their families for
besmirching the Islamic honour of their
families and you know you hear about
honor killings and you hear about
statistics and people say well you know
91 percent of the honor killings in the
world take place in Islamic contexts and
these things are justified by various
rulings and Islamic law but 91 percent
is a number never before had public
attention been brought to these are
these are girls these are human beings
these are people that ought to have been
saved and protected and here again this
kind of thing had never been attempted
before all the time the groups like care
are on the offensive and are making us
play catch up and react to them never
before had they been put on the
defensive and of course the crowning the
culmination of all this was how she made
the Ground Zero mosque a matter of
national discussion and shone a light on
the Imam Feisal Abdul Rauf Pro Sharia
activities his denial of basic freedoms
in the United States his call for
restrictions on freedom of speech his
ties to the jihad flotilla against
Israel and so many other things such
that Daisy Kahn his wife identified the
next winner as being the leader of the
opposition to the mosque and then the
Islamic attack machine went into high
gear she became a lightning rod for
abuse from the left from the mainstream
media and it continues it continues on a
more or less daily basis I remember
seeing a
Peace in a major publication and
thinking well you know these things are
going to happen with the left
controlling the media and then the next
day there was another and another and
another one after the other and just a
couple nights ago you may have seen the
illustrious Keith Olbermann named her
the worst person in the world actually
for a controversy she had nothing to do
with but now she's a symbol you know a
symbol of freedom and a symbol that we
will never give up
and so you know the old saying if you're
getting flak you know you're over the
target if they're screaming you know
they're hitting them hard and she never
gives up and continues to work with
passionate vision insight immense love
for the West for America for Israel for
civilization we live in so cheap and
tawdry and age that all you have to do
to be a hero today is tell the truth
and yet there are so few heroes because
if you dared to tell the truth you will
be made to pay a very great price and
yet the next winner of this award is
someone who has paid it and paid it with
great courage and with a great joy in
life that is an inspiration to me
personally in my work with her it is my
great pleasure and honor
therefore to present the Andy Taylor
award to a true hero a great warrior for
the right whom I'm proud to say is my
friend and colleague pamela geller
oh my god you see mom miracles really do
happen I don't think she thought I would
amount to much I had two sisters that
were doctors and and you know you could
you can become President of the United
States but you're not a doctor first I
want to thank my colleague my friend and
whom the person I consider to be the
world's leading count the jihadist
Robert Spencer
he joined forces with me a couple of
years ago and it started with the Aqsa
Parvez memorial honor killing victim in
Canada who was buried in an unmarked
grave and I wanted to raise the money
just to get her a marker and that was
the beginning of the partnership and I
can't thank him enough for supporting
every initiative no matter how dangerous
he never ever tried to talk me out of
anything that I wanted to do we wanted
to do we started the freedom Defense
Initiative we started to stop the
Islamization of America I tip my hat to
him
even the the the involvement that I have
with the David Horowitz Center I have to
again thank Robert and any time I
approach the David Horowitz Center if I
was one of the events I wanted to do
with CPAC the largest conservative
gathering in America to bring some
education in terms of jihad to CPAC
David Horowitz would always get me the
room these are small things but they're
important because as this past year has
seen you don't need an enormous amount
of people or money to make the
difference you take the enemy's playbook
and you shove it right down their throat
and that's what I did
very briefly the freedom the freedom bus
ads you know I was covering the rifka
berry case and this was the back story
is a Christian convert out of Islam
father threatens to kill her she runs
away so now she's in Florida and they're
trying to bring her back to the to the
household the devout Muslim household
that wants to kill her mind you there
are girls who run away by the millions
they're doing drugs they're selling
bodies nobody's looking for them but
this little virgin with the straight-a
student they're tracking her like a
serial killer
so when I was in Florida I would see
these bus ads privatising for a slum
come to Islam why Islam and I thought
what about those that want to leave
Islam and that's how it started and the
reason why was so pivotal was because on
these television shows where they say
you know that Iran to your slum these
around to your slum dog out I'd say how
they answer you some ads if I did an ad
for spousal abuse that's like every
husband in America saying hurry I'm
insulted we got to say things that we
never said in the media the Ground Zero
mosque sadly we know they're going to go
forward listen listen you have to
understand that we're in a war we are at
war now it's not coming it's not around
the corner it's now the Ground Zero
mosque is the second wave of the 9/11
attack and when I appear on television
and I say things like it's an Islamic
pattern to build triumph row mosques on
the conquered sites cherished sites of
conquered lands people never heard that
people never heard why not build a
shrine to the 270 million victims of
jihadi Wars culture annihilations
land appropriations and enslavement
people never heard that before
it's a teachable moment
and I'm sure it's gotten quiet at the
Ground Zero mosque because they have to
show the money here he's a slumlord
Rakeem on roof whose buildings just went
into receivership
but he's building a one hundred and
fifty million dollar mosque and Sharif
el-gamal the developer on it
he was just thrown out of his offices
and Soho solar properties and he's
building a one hundred and fifty million
dollar mosque they know that the
flashlight is on them and so they're
gonna have to move very carefully and
yes when they break down when they break
ground there's gonna be moms and their
kids and with little stroll is standing
up there move us we are under attack
obviously the violent jihad the academic
jihad the sociological jihad the
cultural jihad the academic jihad we
have been infiltrated at the senior
level of the DoD the Department of
Defense I mean look at what you'll put
through to travel look at what you're
put through to travel and yet not one
time in the in the Department of
Defense's report on the Fort Hood jihadi
not once with religious motivation
mentioned yesterday we had the verdict
in the first Gitmo trial acquitted of
280 counts guilty of destroying property
so what does this mean it means that
understand that it was doctors and
lawyers and moms and dads and kids and
aunts and uncles they were the target in
9/11 and beyond they were the target
they are the soldiers we are the
soldiers now this is not a conventional
war each one of you must fight this war
I cannot impress this upon you enough
you are each activated what does that
mean it means you have friends you have
an email list yes you have to when you
wake up in the morning and you throw
your legs over the bed and you rub the
sleep from your eye you ask yourself
what
am I going to do today to save the
Republic I mean it
we have not yet recovered the bodies
from 9/11 and we're under attack
with the Ground Zero mega mosque and
make no mistake Cordoba iconic of
Islam's conquering the West it's quite
deliberate he could call it whatever he
wants
believe me to the Ummah it is a
triumphal mosque because one schmuck in
New York says it's a mosque of healing
doesn't make it so it's ridiculous it's
insulting there is no action that's too
small we see that the media is
completely and utterly corrupt we see
this the greatest act of perfidy in
American history they did not vet our
presidential candidate so we know this
but it's key that you get the
information out there it is incumbent
upon you you go to your favorite
websites I am sure atlas shrugs and she
had watches on there but we are
reporting news that you do not get
anywhere else you send it around that is
how the Ground Zero mosque became a
story that I've been writing about it
for months
somebody took the pictures of our first
rally where I expected a couple hundred
ten thousand people showed up and sent
that in around in an email and it went
viral I'm sure you guys got it the
censored rally the mystery rally that
that was the first major news story
national news story that went to number
one and international without the media
that shows you how powerful you are
whatever you if you're not into email
then you have to volunteer to precinct
you have to get on the school board look
what they did in Texas with the
textbooks you have to take your country
back you must do it nobody is exempt
there are no exemptions in this war and
I promise you they may have the big guns
they may have the big media and the big
attack edenia and you may have the big
arsenal but we we are good and we are
right and we are righteous and we will
win I promise you never give up never
give up
never get in we we will prevail I
promise you we will prevail thank you